boom hello everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Sakia and
today we're sitting down with clear win
what's up how did - yeah we doing
fantastic I'm very grateful to have you
on
I think everyone's gonna have a blast on
this one Cleese background is super
interesting he's a founder of quantum
gravity research and he is also an
associate founder at singularity
University an investor in companies like
moon Express upworthy change.org so
we're gonna be diving into reality we're
gonna be diving into physics we're gonna
be diving into maximizing human
potential all these cool consciousness
just we're gonna we're gonna have a good
time this is gonna be a blast yes and
guys for you tuning in at home if you
guys want to get exclusive content if
you want to get access to chatting with
our speakers get access to exclusive
video access to live events ahead of
time all that good stuff check us out on
patreon the links in the bio all right
so let's talk about your background
clean because you are Auto didactic use
yourself taught right what how have you
been doing that over the last decade or
so oh well I think I have a DD so
basically learning something in a rote
fashion I can't get my mind to track it
for very long because as soon as I get
into it my mind branches out and start
synthesizing my own extrapolations right
so when I got out of high school I
started college but basically a couple
years after starting college I just had
all these ideas on how to make money and
build companies so I just dove in and
maxed out my credit cards and joined the
entrepreneurial
adventure we are the same in that sight
yeah and so anyway and so then in
business I I'm a fast learner because
with a DD since you can't pay attention
to that which is boring for very long
you better figure things out and
synthesize your model of what's going on
in the world or in a situation quickly
so you put things together quickly while
while your short attention span is there
and then conversely you have this
ability to focus in obsessively like a
laser on that which stimulates you or
interest you so with with
entrepreneurialism you know we grew very
rapidly we figured out how to eclipse
the competition in our industry at the
time you know which was nutriceuticals
you know herbal and vitamin supplements
for you know for treating you know
various health goals so then we we
became a publicly traded company and I
had to learn very rapidly the technical
details of this industry the legal
details and how to deal with a company
that grows very fast and exceeds a
hundred employees in a very short period
of time and where you have new HR things
new all sorts of new challenges so
anyway so I went through I went through
that learning process and I think
creativity is key in business obviously
and creativity is about how rapidly you
can synthesize different combinatorics
of ideas and innovate and solve problems
and and so somehow my mindset of of
creativity and
short attention span for that which is
boring counterbalance by laser like
obsession yeah which interests me yes
that that that worked and then after 15
years of doing that I got a sort of
mission right and my mission was was
about philanthropy so I met Peter
Diamandis and and he said have you ever
thought about philanthropy and I said
what's philanthropy almost right I had
not thought about philanthropy because
as an entrepreneur starting in your 20s
you you work you know you work 80 hours
a week and you yes bring put your head
above water to even think about anything
yes so anyway then Peter really got me
thinking about it I went to this meeting
Aubrey de Grey was there and about you
know director of NASA's Ames Research
Center Pete worden and a whole bunch of
other cool people like Larry Page were
there and I and I really got inspired by
these people who want to use their money
and their technological and innovation
abilities to help do good in the world
and not just rely on governments or
others in power to do it but to go out
and try to try to address the problem
with with the entrepreneurial mindset
really so then I came back to Lausanne
that was at the Ames Center at Moffett
Field and it was that oh that was nine
let's say a good about nine years ago
and so then I came back to LA and I
started thinking wow so how how can I
give back you know how can I do
something that does good in the world
besides making money cuz there's an
entrepreneur you focused on to me
entrepreneurs they're focused on the
game so it's not just about making money
it's just like monopoly it's about
innovating and
and and and being creative and growing
and competing and so I thought well how
can i how can I take that innovation and
and think big
like high-impact world-changing ideas
and so really I just gravitated toward
fundamental physics because it seems to
me that all of the sciences from
genetics to quantum computing everything
really is like an upside down pyramid
resting on the most simple aspects of
reality which is where there lives a a
grand problem that hasn't been resolved
yet which is well how does this theory
of space and time general relativity
how does it live and agree with this
theory of everything else which is
quantum mechanics because both of those
theories imply that the other is
incorrect in real deep and serious ways
and so perhaps if we had that underlying
unification theory it would lead to a
golden age of rapid technological
improvement yes which could help the
world good especially with suffering you
know I mean having more convenient
gadgets is cool but to really take care
of the third of the world or so that is
that is suffering right because of lack
of of resources that's that's exciting
so I put my mind to that and have been
doing that now for going on ten years I
walked up to my assistants desk and I
said hey Stephanie I'm gonna quit life
as a business man and you know and try
to solve the theory of everything do you
want to come and so we walked out of the
building and never went back and so the
company still exists but I but I am not
not very involved with it you know I
work full time leading a group of about
probably 18 or 20 people who are working
on
these fundamental physics questions in
three groups three companies actually
one is an experimental group working on
cold fusion which is nowadays called
low-energy nuclear reactions another
experimental group both of these are in
silicon beach in los angeles and the
second group works on topological
quantum computing and then the third
group was the first group the
theoretical group working on the
unification physics story so the the two
tech companies are essentially taking a
theoretic predictions from the quantum
gravity unification group and then going
out and trying to create world-changing
technologies you know high-risk
high-reward companies because you're in
the sector of energy clean energy and
and you're in the sector of quantum
computing which is a big wild card
because nobody knows how quantum
computing will change the world
holy cow you are a man of incredible
past and present and I love your drive
for now philanthropy and your drive for
understanding unification theory this is
I'm I'm in awe and I really appreciate
your that nine years ago though that
moment for you of how can I help make
the world better in our conversation
with Jordan Peterson on just Saturday
the 17th we were talking about
competence and how people that have high
amounts of competence actually really
love helping other people yeah yeah it's
fun and it's rewarding and it just seems
like once you catch the bug of doing
good in the world it becomes a way of
life and you look back and you say wow
how how was I just living a mostly
selfish you know ambition
because you can have both you can take
care of your needs and and your family
needs and and and do massive good in the
world so I really have to say again I
credit Peter Diamandis for triggering
that and all the other guys and women
who were at that first meeting where we
talked about starting singularity
University I mean they really honestly
inspired me in a big way so yeah and now
you guys are all off and inspiring
people through tons of different mediums
including singularity University as well
as your Research Institute so alright so
I kind of want to start a little bit to
your past because you were describing
how you really loved doing your
laser-like focus on the things that you
cared about and that seemed to be the
most kind of fundamental principle of
your of your 20s and your
entrepreneurial passion there seems to
be a lot of people that are around this
age group or that are living life right
now in their entrepreneurial time zone
that are kind of following a similar
mindset of how do I find how do I focus
on the thing that I love doing how do I
kind of let the other things be and
really hone in and how do I bring that
to the world how right what may be
recommendations would you have for that
Wow you know I'll tell you I get asked
this question so there are a group of
people who asked me this question and
they know what their mission and their
passion is and then there are other
people who asked me that same question
and they don't know and they say so Klee
how do you how do you find out what your
what your highest purpose is or your
your your passion or your mission
because I'm interested in three or four
things and I really don't know yet and I
mean perhaps it comes when it comes
because for me it just came like a
lightning bolt I didn't try to conjure
up this clarity it just it just happened
and when it happened I knew I can't go
back to this old life as a businessman
where my only thing is just contracts
marketing and sales in the whole process
of running a midsize company but I do
think that you can also search you know
like the Native American kind of quest
you know to find out that when you
become a teenager what your what your
mission is I think that you can simply
say you know I'm going to go inwards or
I'm gonna go on a retreat or I'm gonna
just think maybe go to inspiring things
like for me going to singularity
University's first discussion meeting
before there was a singularity for me
that kicked it off but I say just seek
and and try to tune in to this abstract
idea called intuition because if you get
to mental and calculating about it it's
probably not your true mission or
passion it has to be this element of
feeling it in your gut like your inner
your inner knowing or intuition yeah and
then how did you follow along with the
laser-like focus as well
oh the laser-like focus just comes
naturally for for me and I suppose that
it may come naturally for anyone who's
doing what their calling is or what
their passion is if if they're freed up
to do that and can make money doing that
then I think the laser-like focus might
just come naturally because if you can
you know it's a cliche thing to say but
if you can go to work to play everyday
exactly I'm going to play exactly you
know it's not even work right it's life
yeah it's love right yeah right okay
good all right and then you you jumped
right into where I think we should
probably go next which is I I kind of
wanted to talk about philanthropy as
well maybe it seems like let's let's go
okay let's go in okay let's go in this
order let's go in this order so in about
nine years ago when you guys were having
those conversations about bringing good
to the world and then
you ended up starting quantum gravity
research but and then simultaneously you
ended up helping with organization like
XPrize and James org and other moon
Express etc along this path so maybe we
talk just a bit before we get to all the
the quantum mechanics and unification
theory let's talk about kind of this
prize model it seems to be what is
exciting for so many people is a big
offer of a price to solve a global
challenge and then people pull in their
resources their time and their money to
try and solve that problem and earn that
prize money it seems to be eliciting a
lot of innovation yeah that model I'm
certainly no expert on it I did end up
kind of having a serendipitous chain of
events that related to XPrize I took my
daughter for her 10th burst birthday on
one of the zero-g flights which was a
company that Peter had co-founded and so
me and my daughter we went up and we
escaped Earth's gravity for 15 times for
30 seconds of weightlessness each time
and it was an awesome experience and
then it was there that I met Peter who
was also you know working that day on
the flight and then he asked me if I
would do some pro bono marketing
consulting for him at XPrize Foundation
which was in Santa Monica at the time
and I go and I do that and give him all
my two cents of marketing advice and
then he says hey have you ever read the
singularity is near this book really
made an impact on me so I said no like
when I went I read it and that book made
an impact on me I don't agree with all
of reycarts Wyles
take on things but I agree with the
notion of exponential change and
emergence and so then I and then from
what I what I come came to appreciate
about the prize model is back to the
word fun so
you look like you're having fun what
you're doing so you go to work everyday
to play and so if you can if you can
turn research and development from the
very heavy idea of corporate competition
and lose your job or lose your company
or lose your stock value if you fail hmm
or or academics with all of its politics
and often constriction of outside the
box ideas if you can turn it into a big
gamified competition in a prize then
obviously where there is fun there is
more creativity and boom then you've got
it then you've got outside the box ideas
and every once in a while one of those
outside the box ideas that comes from
the creativity of play changes the world
so yeah I think it's a smart I think
that IIIi don't think it's a trend or a
fad that's gonna go away I think that
the that the that this gamified model of
prizes for R&D yeah is is we're just
seeing the beginning any of it of it
yeah yeah I love how you keep bringing
up play and play being the central theme
of life dancing through the fabric of
space/time and you're really enjoying
whatever you do everyday to the extent
where it doesn't feel like work where it
feels like fun and play and that's kind
of where the s your your actualization
your essence will come from as well as
helping the world will come from that as
well
okay so emergence theory yes you kind of
you gave us a little taste at the
beginning when you talked about an
upside-down triangle yes give us a
little taste of that so this has been
your last about nine years yes of
research into that I think people are
familiar with the word quark yeah seems
to be the most smallest thing that we
can discuss and then interestingly
enough the largest thing we can discuss
a universe
and then between those two things is
apparently a human yeah right in the
middle yeah so interesting so maybe yeah
what is in what is this you know this
cork and this emergence theory how does
quantum mechanics relate with that your
research ok start us from the beginning
well ok so well let's think of the idea
of pixelation so we can have a nice 4k
video monitor that has fluidic patterns
and smoothness playing at some framerate
and you'd have no idea that the
framerate is actually underneath what
appears to be continuous time and
continuous motion that that between the
steps of motion on this 4k video monitor
a particle moving from here to here it
doesn't traverse the infinity of steps
between here and here at the pixilated
level of frame-by-frame time and pixel
by pixel position change if you zoom in
small enough to time and small enough to
the space of your pixels on your monitor
you will see that the smoothness of
smooth time and smooth space was
illusionary so quantum mechanics is part
of the story and it gives us clues about
nature as though Mother Nature is
whispering in our ear
I am pixelated down to the core in every
way including space and time now what we
know so far as a consensus view is that
nature is pixelated in terms of things
like spin so particle can have either
spin up or spin down and we have a
quantum of angular momentum we have a
quantum of we have these quanta of these
actions and particle physics so in some
sense it's a pixelated view but we
haven't gone so far yet as to suppose as
to agree that even space and time
where these particles play out is a
pixelated reality and so the search for
quantum gravity means the search to
unify quantum mechanics which tells you
everything about particle physics and
the theory of space and time
Einstein's general relativity they don't
yet fit together and part of the reason
is because the theory of general
relativity makes a conjecture or an
axiomatic choice with no proof that
space is smooth so that between any two
moments there are an infinity of other
moments not pixelated
and that in that space so space and time
are smooth and so that this quantum
mechanics and particle physics plays out
in this absolute smoothness but if that
weren't the case and that's somehow at
this very smallest scale of reality
which is called the Planck scale which
is actually a length and a volume and a
time implied by quantum mechanics yes
Planck playing the Planck time the
Planck volume yes so then it's so
fantastically small it's well well
beyond the ability of our particle
accelerators or any possible current
technology to zoom in to that level
where the Planck length and volume and
time are so all one can do is speculate
so we can speculate and make a choice
with logic that either space and time
are pixelated like your video monitor or
they're smooth like the common sense
more ancient paradigm of this smoothness
like it seemed smooth so I mean it
wasn't a hundred years ago when people
actually thought water was a
continuously smooth medium and then it
was found out that it was pixelated with
these little clusters called h2o
molecules but only a hundred years ago
or so that was not known to be true
Einstein actually proved in 1905 that
molecules exist
you know in one of his three three
famous papers that he wrote in that
miracle year and so anyway so what we're
doing at quantum gravity research is
we're we're part of a community of
physicists around the world who are
working on this idea of quantized or
pixelated space-time our approach is is
different than the other popular
approaches to that and so here's where
it could get a little complicated but
hopefully not too much so so the most
expensive thing that humans have ever
built is the Large Hadron Collider and
Geneva Switzerland not only is it the
most expensive thing it's also the
largest thing 27 miles it's it's it's
also the most technologically
sophisticated thing that Large Hadron
Collider is the the epitome of mankind's
highest technology in various fields and
what is that big thing and who paid for
it well it was so expensive that one
country couldn't even get taxpayer
dollars to afford it so people pitched
in right various nations pitched in and
and paid for this thing and all it is is
a microscope it's a giant microscope to
peer down as close to the direction of
this pixilated Planck scale of reality
that we can peer for the purpose of
understanding unification physics and
because it's generally believed that if
mankind discovers this unification
theory it will usher in a new golden age
of rapidly advancing technology perhaps
it could occur in star trek level
technology 200 years early mm-hmm so
there's so that's why governments paid
the money for this giant microscope and
what have we gotten from this giant
microscope and the earlier lower
resolutions before that like the SLA see
here in Stanford well what we've gotten
is a bunch of numbers and those come by
colliding particles together at high
energy and those numbers easily which
particles are we on so neutrons for
example okay will be collided together
and then you'll see in the collision
you'll see these angles and these
particle transformations occur okay so a
bunch of data from smashing particles
together and that data has been
assembled into this model which is an
extension of the theory of quantum
mechanics combined with all this
particle accelerator data that is called
the standard model of particle physics I
think a lot of physicists would agree
it's the most sophisticated and powerful
physical model that mankind has so far
so it explains everything except the
theory of space and time gravity that is
gravitational theory and so anyway so
one interesting thing about this
standard model of particle physics that
we have as a result of machines like the
Large Hadron Collider is for some reason
the way all these fundamental particles
and forces except for gravity convert
into one another is according to these
higher dimensional crystals and algebras
so they're called Li algebras and a
given Li algebra has an Associated
geometric object which is a higher
dimensional crystal or lattice so that
the particle is made up of no how it's
it's a mathematical thing so let's say
that so we understand from the standard
model how how a photon can become a
neutrino which can become an electron
which can become a quark and how all
these things these this small this zoo
or small set of fundamental irreducible
particles how one can become the others
and and so it's a it's a unification
model so it's unifying all particles and
forces the standard model
with full compliance with quantum
mechanics except for gravity it doesn't
know what to do with gravity so it's a
it's a unification model and for some
reason the mathematics of how all these
things interconvert or transform into
the others and unify maps to the
vertices of these higher dimensional
polytopes shapes so think of platonic
solid shapes that are in higher
dimension like a tesseract is a four
dimensional cube so these higher
dimensional shapes which are which map
to these higher dimensional algebra is
called lee algebras and mat and the
shapes map to these crystals just the
way a cube would map to a cubic crystal
right or a square lattice on a on some
grid paper is made of squares so that's
the polytope and the lattice is just a
repeating of that shape so so why why
does reality relate to these higher
dimensional shapes why mathematically is
that true we don't know so nobody knows
deeply why that is but it's it is the
case and it's non-controversial what's
controversial is when people try to
bring gravity and space-time Theory into
it because there's no mathematically
convincing argument for that which which
a consensus of people agree on but we
know that everything else maps to these
strangely to these higher dimensional
shapes and crystals and so what we do is
we take one of those higher dimensional
crystals and we project it
mathematically like this here we're
projecting it to the wall so this is in
3d and as it goes to the wall angles get
rearranged lengths get shorter and we
have a transformation but the shadow
encodes everything here so if you knew
how to do that the trigonometry you
could take that shadow and
reverse-engineer it and say not only was
the light at this exact angle to the
object but but here's the
the description of the object just from
the lower dimensional shadow so what a
quasi crystal is is it is an irrational
projection right of a higher dimensional
crystal so we take the e8 lattice or
crystal and we project a slice of it
mathematically to lower dimensions 4d
and 3d and we get an object which is the
shadow or the projection called a quasi
crystal and a quasi crystal is a great
way to pixelate space-time because it's
a code so a crystal is not really a code
because we now free and I think I'm yeah
pixely space-time yes that's okay
because so much of this is over my head
because you've obviously been studying
it for so long I'm trying to keep up and
then follow through so let's kind of
let's move back to that start and then
let's get back to this distal okay so
pixelation of space-time right we do
think that that is what is going on or
we don't think so we're part of a
community of people who are working on
quantum gravity theories so most people
working on quantum gravity or many of
them are presuming that space and time
are pixelated now that's not a technical
term that yeah that's just we use the
word quantized or discretized but it's
the same as the word pixelated and it's
real a more relatable I think yeah for
people because they know the pixels on
their devices and right like that so in
in pixelation of space-time would be
down to this level of link length
exactly so the pixels will be little
volumes so be the Planck volume and time
would just be different so the Planck
volume okay yeah be where the lattice
this crystal is yeah yeah yes that's
where the quasi crystal is that and the
interesting thing about quasi crystals
is they are languages geometric codes
for example if I give you the black and
white and red squares to make a
checkerboard it's not a code because you
have to put it together exactly the way
it
to be put together to make the
checkerboard so you have no freedom
syntax freedom to express any patterns
in there it's not a code crystals are
not codes but quasi crystals are codes
because how they're assembled comes with
rules so you have a set of shapes and
then you have rules on how you can
arrange the shapes and then within the
rules you have some syntactical freedom
so you can you can match this like this
or you can match this like this so you
have freedom and once you have syntax or
freedom in a set of ordering rules like
english then you can express all sorts
of meaning okay so at the Planck length
we have a quasi crystal yeah and then at
that level we have a the the
checkerboard can only be arranged in the
way that the checkerboard makes sense
but the quasi crystal also can't be that
has the freedom it has the freedom yes
to be arranged in and so this is kind of
the the upside-down pyramid well this
would be the bottom of the pyramid so
this this would be if it's real then
this would be at what we call a first
principles unification theory so first
principles means that when we take in
Stein's general theory of relativity or
we take the standard model that I
mentioned as the the most advanced
theory we have we have these things
called free parameters which come from
things we observe but where we don't
know why they are the values they are
for example the gravitational constant
or the electron rest mass so we get
these values that we get from
measurements and with measurements we
never know with full accuracy what the
real measurement is we just get
approximations because the fidelity
right of our equipment is only is always
limited and so with most models well
with all models really physical models
you take a free parameter that
get from your observables in the
standard model there are 20 free
parameters just things you plug in and
then you work the math around that so
the model itself never explains why the
values are like we don't know today why
the speed of light has the magnitude it
has for example that's an that's a great
example so at first principles
unification theory would give you the
the speed of light and tell you why it
has the magnitude it has from first
principles so this would be this idea
this story I'm sharing at the bottom of
the pyramid of all of physical sciences
would be this code a geometric language
that has that comes from these higher
dimensional lattices which are already
known to encode realistic unification
physics except for gravity and and buy
things like particles things all the
particles and forces by electromagnetism
right everything except for
gravitational theories so that's the now
there are people who try to will bring
that down to the point now so we we just
mathematically say to get the code we
take this higher dimensional thing
because like the shadow on the wall with
the lower dimensional projection you can
recover or decode you can recover unfold
all of the information of the higher
dimensional thing so if we have if we
have it's called gauge symmetry
unification physics that's the standard
model of particle physics everything
explained with gauge symmetry except for
gravity so if we simply rework the math
by projecting the hyper lattice slice
down to a lower dimension we can recover
within the mathematics of the projection
which is the quasi crystal we can
recover the gauge symmetry unification
physics that's not that's not a problem
the challenge is to understand the code
right because the quasi crystal if I
give you the rules for a quasi crystal
and give you a few tiles of it of a
two-dimensional for example quasi
crystal you would easily learn how to
play with those rules and build some
nice patterns and you would have an
understanding of your syntactical
freedom so
I gave you only eight tiles of there's a
famous quasicrystal called the Penrose
tiling it's just a two-dimensional
tiling like you it's actually the tiles
that you would see on a Muslim mosque
okay it's that that those those tilings
made with a few simple shapes and you
might discover with only eight tiles and
following the rules you might say hey
clean have five different ways I can
arrange these eight tiles and I would
say exactly now if you do the five
Arrangements in a certain order you can
make a pattern like an animation if you
were to play those five one after or the
other just like on your video monitor if
you were to play at 24 frames per second
frozen images changing on your pixelated
screen you can create the illusion of
particles or movement okay I've I've
probably never felt like a
three-year-old more than I do right now
trying to understand something that's so
damn complicated and interesting and so
important for Humanity okay I okay so
we're let's pixelate space-time and then
let's say that at the very very small
pixelation is the Planck length right
and that whatever we understand that
we've done with like the Large Hadron
Collider with particle physics now we're
trying to bring that similar style of
math and geometric understanding to the
Planck length exactly we get all that
for free by doing by taking our
projection from the e8 lattice then we
have the unification physics that people
have done on the lower dimensional
lattices that live inside e8 or people
like Garrett Lisi who do work on e8 and
others string theory original strength
area was done with two copies of e8 for
example so we get all of that for free
what we're working on now this year is
exactly what is the nature of the code
and how do these qualities are called
quasi-particles so when I met when I
said you have those five ways that you
can arrange in if you make an
arrangement in a certain way that makes
an illusionary pattern like a
propagating blip right that would be
called a quasi particle so we would say
in physics the things we call particles
are actually these illusionary quasi
particles that come from ordered
patterns ordered sets of these legal
configurations of the closet crystal
because you can you can make it in
several ways and so that's that's what
we're working on now and of course the
big the big issue is so how do we bring
in the theory of space and time and
gravity into this picture and that's
that's the grand challenge that no one
has figured out yet in a way that makes
predictions and gets consensus within
the scientific community the unification
theory is going to drive like you said
an acceleration to the Star Trek future
right and I I love people that are
diving into this face first and
understanding it better right but it's
so amazing to learn from you along along
your journey right now okay so that's
the let's now let's chunk okay let's
chunk up what you're doing at quantum
gravity research so we have the
unification theory you're pushing for
that and then we have a couple other
pushes as well so yeah so quantum
computing is one of them yes and then
the other one is the cold fusion that's
right okay so these are two startup
companies in Silicon Beach Los Angeles I
love calling it silicon beach by the way
I do too yeah and so they're in some
sense they're separate companies but in
some sense if they were if they were
part of quantum gravity research we
would call them experimental divisions
right so those would be the the people
the scientist
trying to test out a theoretical
experimental prediction of the the
people in the theoretical group so we
got this idea that you can use this
quasi crystal mathematics and material
science because quasi crystals
physically exist in nature they were
discovered in 1984 to be physical phases
of matter that are possible prior to 84
it was believed it was impossible for
them to exist and they physical quasi
crystals they they have a lot of
interesting anomalies so there's
photonic anomalies thermal dynamic
anomalies so an anomaly just means
something that you observe
experimentally that the best theories of
the day say cannot possibly be true
and since experiment always Trump's
theory when it's clearly experimentally
evident even if it has no theory that
says that it's okay it's called an
anomaly
so it's an orphan observable fact
because it has no parent theory to allow
it to be true and yet it's true so we
have all these anomalies in atomic scale
you know physical quasi crystals and so
we're using these mathematically
abstract quasi crystals for the
mathematics at the Planck scale and and
so at at emergence which is the quantum
computing company we're using physical
quasi crystals to build an ideal
topological quantum computer so no one
has built a topological quantum computer
so kiddie EV at Caltech what's the
difference between quantum heating in
topological quantum computing well
they're both quantum computing and
topological quantum computers would be
quantum computing that you do with a
topological phase of matter and a
topological phase of matter is is any
phase of matter that you
massively entangled so your quantum
entanglement reaches a threshold where
it displays these qualities which define
it as a topological phase of matter
called it's called the fractional
quantum Hall effect but really what it
means is that the matter is exquisitely
and massively entangled or connected in
in bizarre ways because quantum
mechanics is bizarre
it's just non-local non-intuitive non
normal and so these are exotic phases of
matter and kiddie Evette Caltech
theorized some years ago that you could
build a topological quantum computer and
so you have this space race going on
with Google Intel Microsoft China IBM
and pretty much all the major players in
the field are pursuing non topological
quantum computing except for Microsoft
so Microsoft stands as the sort of lone
wolf of the big guys because their bet
they're gambling on the idea that kiddie
herbes idea of topological quantum
computing is the ideal quantum computer
hmm because with nature we have limits
right there's a limit to the how fast
something can go for example in the
speed of light and so logically there
there should be a limit for a given
amount of mass of how much quantum
computation nature would allow in say
one second but because we don't really
deeply understand the theory of quantum
computing yet and we don't even really
deeply understand quantum mechanics for
that matter science as a whole
Richard Feynman famously said I think it
is safe to say that no one understands
quantum mechanics not really so anyway
no one succeeded Microsoft hasn't
succeeded in actually building a
topological quantum computer and there
has been in recent years some limited
success in building very small and not
so helpful
quantum computers not topological
quantum computers so there's this sort
of space race to figure out who's the
who's the company who can come up with a
powerful and helpful quantum computer
that changes the world first and it's
it's a race in a way
unlike the space race going to the moon
where we're really just using
technologies that were understood and
and it was a race to see who can take
things that we understand and build
machines quick enough to go to the moon
but in this race for for this idea
called quantum supremacy which is the
buzzword name for the race it's it's the
race that involves a lot of unknowns
because we don't deeply understand this
this regime of where quantum mechanics
and material science and perhaps even
quantum gravity all interplay and so
there's a lot of theoretical speculation
and creativity in this race so we are a
way smaller group but maybe we get lucky
and we have an outside-the-box
innovation that gives us a sort of
inside track to to maybe having a David
and Goliath story with the big the big
boys and I love the term quantum
supremacy because then there's also AI
supremacy and generics of privacy Mars
supremacy whatever all their supremacy
there is maybe you kind of give us a
quick idea into what you think's going
on with the whole geopolitical sphere
with these racist supremacist do you
think that how we need to actually work
together or in terms of the interaction
between the different technological
races and different yeah and different
countries yeah yeah well that's a great
question because for me innovation is
about combinatorics right that's about
combining ideas so this guy over here
did this experiment and we heard about
that that that proves that this is
possible
and then this woman over here did this
paper on this theory and they seem
unrelated but what if they're related
and then you realize oh my god they're
totally related so it's about combining
right and if you put up walls to block
the connectivity of a neural network or
a network on the internet of minds or a
scientific community because for example
you know let's say you're in the Trump
administration and you believe that too
much collaboration and allowing
scientists from other countries to come
here is stealing American jobs and and
that's your only mindset then you cut
off collaboration and mixing things for
better combinatorics mm-hmm so you cut
off your nose to spite your face works
combinatorics very interesting similar
to how I discuss I guess polymath yeah
on disciplines or interdisciplinary
research things like that Ryan
combinatorics
yeah because whatever they're
researching right now about AI are
quantum computing or genetic engineering
in China or Russia or wherever could be
worked with the US as research or with
whatever other countries research and
meat into something better than what it
is and cross-disciplinary so even within
a university you tend to have silos yes
where this department doesn't do a lot
of interaction with this so for example
here is a fun party trick you're at a
wedding and you're running the wedding
and you're trying to plan these 16 C
round tables and you have this one
special table where you've got you know
the bride and groom's parents and
brothers and sisters and there's 16
people and you want to arrange the name
cards around the table so that when they
all come to sit down they enjoy
themselves with lively conversations
right so you're thinking about all the
ways that you can combine these 16
people around the table most people
wouldn't guess that the number of
combinatorics of ways you could arrange
just 16 people around a table is almost
22 trillion
with a tea so when it comes to
combinatorics of ideas it's a nearly
infinite set of combinatorics with the
large amount of ideas that we have so
that so what we don't want to do is cut
off the connectivity of the neural
network of Minds we want to allow the
free-flowing connectivity and through
our politics our ways of engineering our
societies we need to open that up we'll
all be better off in the end we'll be
more prosperous jobs will be better but
if you cut off the connections because
you think that in the near term you're
gonna save a job or or out-compete or
something better than team opens biggest
one the biggest one is the concern of
competition right that's the biggest one
right that is siloing people off of one
another yeah but I really love your
perspective about combinatorics and open
sourcing the collaboration across
disciplines and across countries yeah I
love that I I do think that that's
that's without a doubt going to be the
future yes but I think right now there's
so much discussion about competition
that is writing people back from that
right yeah so and we can dive deeper
into that but I want to just cycle
quickly back to quantum computing
explained at the most basic level is it
the ability to leverage quantum
mechanics for computing yes there are
various ways to think about it perhaps
imagine if reality were similar to this
story that I've been sharing with you
where there isn't actually smooth motion
that what you perceive as motion is
these frozen States frozen quasi crystal
frames at the Planck scale and that it
the frame rate is so fast so the frame
rate if it were the Planck time would be
happening 10 to the 44 times every
second so that's just 10 with 44 zeroes
every second second right solvent of
that yeah that's the plank time and the
Planck length and volume is similarly
small it's beyond our ability to measure
with today's technology but but if it
were happening at that frame rate then
in some sense you can use the analogy of
CPU speed and you could say reality is
playing out at a CPU speed of 10 to the
44 times per second now how could you
tap into that nearly infinite speed yes
to bring it up to the atomic scale to
build computers and devices that can
enjoy that ultra ultra high frequency
that's just game-changing that is just
right away who whatever whoever however
we figure that out that is right that's
way more than what we have right now in
terms of ability to the process yes and
I must say just to give balance to the
other side the Copenhagen interpretation
of quantum mechanics postulates this
idea called wave particle duality and it
says that until you measure something it
is in a superposition like a ghostly
state of being let's say if it could be
at this position or this position then
the quantum superposition says that it's
in both at the same time and neither at
the same time how its measured until
it's measured now that's a that is an
interpretation or a conjecture of the
statistical mathematics of quantum
mechanics so then there are others that
plane could be at ten to the forty four
position well imagine if imagine if this
glass were moving back and forth from
this position to this position back and
forth at ten to the forty four times per
second yeah now of course you could
never measure that all you would do is
you take up a position medicine
measurement and you would say well at
that time I took the measurement it was
here
so I've collapsed the quantum wave
function and until I measured it I can
say fill
sophocles I can say it was in both
positions at the same time or neither
that's the way of particle duality
philosophy or conjecture or I could say
that it's moving immeasurably fast back
and forth which is virtually a
superposition because if I were to move
it back and forth infinitely fast well
then that is technically exactly the
superposition idea infinitely fast it's
in both it's in neither yeah okay so
that's branch two and then okay so then
branch three is low-energy nuclear
reaction so now we're so many people
understand nuclear energy as in fission
and fission produces waste and fission
produces the not the non ideal
circumstances for having a long living
civilization fusion produces what
happens in our star yeah and what if we
could figure out how to do that at the
at the level of just fusing hydrogen
together at maybe a the cost of a dollar
instead of the cost of 99 dollars we
could take out 99 dollars worth of
energy versus just one dollar of energy
and make it really effective forever and
then that would be amazing for us yes so
that's a great analogy of the 99 dollars
and that's exactly a good way to
understand hot fusion so the nuclear
reactors well what they'll do is they'll
spend a lot of energy usually generated
by coal-fired electric plants and
they'll use that energy to smash
particles together at a very very high
energy and at a high electric cost for
your energy and then when it smashed
together with sufficiently high energy
you can crack open the nuclear energy by
if by getting a fusion event and then
you can harvest that nuclear energy and
so it would be like spending $99
of electricity to smash them together
and getting $1 back except it's worse
than that it's more like 99.99 point
nine nine nine cents and you're getting
back a fraction of a penny but if you do
it enough repeatedly then that fraction
can add up and so that's that is
actually a great analogy for the current
state of nuclear reactors hot fusion
nuclear reactors but it's not as
economically viable as just scooping
soft coal out of the side of a mountain
and burning it and so what if there were
a backdoor key a way to get the nucleons
of two atoms to fuse without forcefully
smashing them together there is a way to
do it so that's the idea of the of the
study of low energy nuclear reactions
high-energy as the inner is smashing
them together low energy nuclear
reaction is this back door this other
way and so in 1989 pons and Fleischmann
published a paper announcing that they
had achieved these reactions they called
it at the time cold fusion because it's
low energy and it was reported on 60
minutes it was a big optimistic exciting
time and then it was followed by a
crashing disappointment so what happened
is pons and Fleischmann published it
then other universities reproduced their
results sometimes so the problem is pons
and Fleischmann could not consistently
reproduce the results sometimes it would
happen sometimes it wouldn't and some of
the other universities had it happen and
then other times they didn't happen so
the literature started filling up with
these early reports after 1989 and
because with experimental physics it
generally should happen every time all
of the time so even though it happened
some of the time it was presumed that
there's some glitch in the experimental
controls and that this was all just a
false alarm and that and that this
there's hope for Humanity reported on
60 minutes of cold fusion saving the
world was actually not real and and even
some people called it a hoax but the US
government through Los Alamos and the US
Naval Institute and various other
government National Labs continued
working on it after 1989 and then as we
got into the 90s and the 2000s various
university groups MIT Stanford groups in
Japan all around the world continued
working so today we have about 2000 peer
review papers in the literature
verifying that cold fusion which is now
called low energy nuclear reactions
because the name cold fusion was ruined
by the controversy at the time in 1989
which you can call it whatever you want
cold fusion is a great clever last yeah
it's a nice word yes so now it's known
only if you're us if you if you're
up-to-date with the literature you know
that it's an it's a it's an accepted
anomaly in physics but if you talk to
any physicist off the campus of Stanford
or anyplace and they're an on subject
matter expert they will have been
exposed to the rumor mill that happened
after 1989 and not be aware that there
are 2,000 peer review papers in the
literature so here's the problem just
because it's an anomaly in physics and
known by subject matter experts to be
real doesn't mean it can help the world
or change the world because in order to
max out on something to potentiate a
physical result you have to have theory
so we can do what we do with electronics
because we understand quantum mechanics
and we understand electromagnetic theory
and so through that theory we're able to
max out on on how we engineer devices
but what happens if you just have this
experimental result of low energy
nuclear energy and you don't have the
theory the new atomic theory that allows
it to be real and so you're stuck with
this anomaly and you don't know how to
tweak it to get something that can
compete with coal or oil and and really
change the world so that's where we're
at now so there's a a big opportunity a
wild card for someone to come along and
Intuit or deduce what the proper nuclear
theory is and so for us the proper
theory comes from our understanding of
studying quantum gravity via the lens of
quasi crystal mathematics so we are
building a very special system of quasi
crystal structured nano engineering in
the topological quantum computer that
we're working on and and if we're
correct we we really owe the credit to
the thinking that we invested over nine
years to think about this quasi crystal
mathematics which it's really not super
complicated it's just I would say that
there are 50 full-time people in the
world outside of our group who work on
quasi crystal physics or math full-time
50 and maybe another couple hundred who
understand it at an expert level so it's
an incredibly arcane and small community
and we're sort of therefore the only
people applying it to unification
physics and quantum gravity and we're
also the only people applying it to low
energy nuclear reactions or quantum
computing okay so to explain the back
door you have to understand this idea
called quantum tunneling okay so the
idea of quantum tunneling is allowed in
quantum mechanics and it says that for
example if I have an atom here where
this glass is or the whole glass for
that matter quantum mechanics actually
allows some statistical probability
for the object at the next time you
measure it to be here without ever
having traversed the infinity of
coordinates between here and here so
that's a weird magical counterintuitive
fact of quantum mechanics just like
entanglement is a weird bizarre idea but
it's fully accepted and allowed by
quantum mechanics so so what would
happen so you have this thing called the
Coulomb barrier and it's like a force
field like in the Star Trek Enterprise
and the Romulan ship if they were to get
too close together while their force
fields are on it would just go boom when
they repel away and as they get closer
the force field is stronger so that's
the Coulomb force field between two at
between two atoms so you as they get
closer the the force field repulsion
gets stronger
so that's why it takes this $99 and
ninety-nine point nine nine nine cents
of of hardcore energy to just force to
muscle them together but what if you
used quantum tunneling instead of
forcing them together it would be like
let's say you have a nice strong wooden
door to your office and you get some
physicists to calculate how much power
it would take to just smash through that
door and you calculate so if you have a
three hundred and twenty pound NFL line
linebacker and you have him run at 22
miles an hour to at the door you'll
smash that sucker down so you've
calculated it and so you can calculate
the amount of energy and calories and
kinetic energy that it took or you can
have an eight-year-old girl just walk
right up to the door and use a half a
pound of pressure to turn the knob and
whisk right through the door so
tunneling is like that eight-year-old
girl turning the knob and going through
the door using not brute force energy so
here's one nucleus here's another I need
them to get to within I need their
Coulomb barriers to overlap once they
overlap this thing that was this amass
simply repulsive force flips sign value
and it becomes a massively attractive
force and then you get fusion and then
there's an energy release so if I had an
atom here and I could get this atom to
quantum tunnel to here or here or here
or any overlap then I could in a fully
legal way with in terms of the legality
of quantum mechanics without violating
quantum mechanics I would have a nuclear
fusion event without having used energy
to smash them together how do you get
them to quantum quantum tunnel to the
point where they break the cool quasi
crystal mathematics and quasi crystal
material science nano engineering and
just and just to make sure the quasi
crystal again is the the quasi crystal
is a particular geometric arrangement of
atoms in three-dimensional space that is
defined mathematically by it as an
irrational projection of a higher
dimensional abstract crystal down to 3d
so even though it's mathematically
abstract it's still the way that the
atoms are arranged in an ordinary three
space space-time so it's the way that
these oxygen atoms yes are currently
arranged and whatever the atoms are
quasi crystals usually like metal atoms
like palladium or aluminum exactly okay
and it's the way that they're arranged
in that metal that has a quasi crystal
and then yeah exactly and so your
question I think I can answer it without
messing it up which is so we have this
idea in quantum mechanics and in classic
physics about energy wells energy
potentials and so it centrally says
these water glasses are serving as great
props here so I'm going to use this
again so if this atom is sitting in an
energy well here what that means is that
there's these force fields from other
atoms around it
that like playing with magnets for
example that prevent it from being
anywhere else like if it goes here this
force field here is like saying oh no
get the hell out of here you can't be
here and there's another one over here
pushing it and so then the only place it
can be is right there now quantum
mechanics allows probabilities for it to
jitter around to even these
energetically inhospitable coordinates
but but statistically quantum mechanics
says well to be here in this difficult
repulsive area it would be exponentially
less probable and so the highest
probability is that is at the bottom of
this energy well so the question is all
right that's great
so let's say we have this energy well
that is this attractive let's use a
metaphor of a real water well so water
well let's say it's 10 meters deep and
and so we have this energy well and so
that's where it is in the energy well
that's where we measure it because
that's the highest probability
but what if about an angstrom away
there's another energy well identical to
this one 10 meters deep
and that energy well being the exact
same depth as the first energy well
makes it equally statistically probable
that it can be in that one because all
the particles want to do is go to where
it is the lowest energy is where they
can survive just like with magnets if
you're playing with a bunch of magnets
and pointing them in different
directions and you put some new magnet
in it's just gonna be where it can
energetically not be repelled as much so
anyway so this would require nano
engineering because you have to get this
energy well to be vacant because you
don't want some other atom occupying it
you want to tempt this one to go to that
tunnel to hear things so we bring it to
low temperature so we know it doesn't
have enough energy to muscle through the
high indicas member if this is an energy
well the energy wells are just defined
by everything else being too repulsively
difficult so we
we want to engineer that with nano
engineering which is the quasi crystal
material science and then what we get
and this is in the observed experiments
within the literature we get tunneling
events of entire atoms metallic atoms
these are massive objects Wow and boom
it's like Star Trek teleportation it's
at time one it's here and then at time
two it just disappears from here and
it's here it never traveled the distance
between a full metal atom yeah like a
palladium atom for it and because you've
cooled the environment it's not just
because it's not so much that we've
cooled the environment would you you've
made a 10 meter well next it's because
we've nano-engineered the 10 meter well
next Dylan repulsed everything else
right away so that it won't fill that
span the cooling comes in to demonstrate
to ourselves experimentally and
theoretically that you can't when at a
certain temperature like liquid nitrogen
temperature you measure this tunneling
now you can't say at that temperature
that this atom had enough energy to
muscle through the infinity of
coordinates between this energy well in
this it's out that becomes out of the
picture quantum mechanically and you're
left deductively with only quantum
tunneling as the explanation so large
you know even even water molecules have
been observed recently to tunnel and
that's a huge step for teleportation in
our future yeah Ron what do you think
about all this quantum world life sounds
crazy doesn't it
I feel like a three-year-old for the
first time on this show like really
three-year-old I love it I love it I
need more people to make me feel like a
three-year-old
I love it okay so that's that's the
essence of what you're up to at quantum
gravity research we had a bunch of
different branches it's gonna take me
another decade of of at least daily to
tapping into quantum understanding to
even catch up to anywhere near where
you're at okay so let's let's ask you a
couple of our simulation questions and
so since you're very versed in the in in
this field let's ask you what is your
definition of time time is change you
can't have the word change without some
notion in your mind of time so at the
simplest irreducible level the idea of
time is the idea of change now change
can either be discrete in the pixelated
way where something is here like on your
video monetary it's just here and then
it's just over here it never on your
video monitor covers necessarily all the
pixels in between especially if it's
just two pixels like it's pics it's here
and then it's here it didn't have
anything in between so time can be
smooth change if that's your philosophy
physically or it can be this notion of
pixelated or discrete change which would
just be an ordered set of frozen things
are you Buddhist I don't follow any
organized religion but I love the
philosophy of Buddhism because it's so
likewise it's so geeky
it's a physics and philosophy merge
merged yeah and exactly not a full
subscriber of religion but yeah I love
how scientific because Buddhism is very
much rooted in the idea of time and
change being
he civ and that's and everything being
impermanent right and so every moment to
moment to moment their new photons
hitting our faces right there's all the
biochemical change that's occurring
within your body where a
moment-to-moment getting closer and
closer to death yes so okay that's
that's good okay let's let's continue
onward and let's ask me about how and
let's let's let's within your
understanding of what you've been
studying within the unification theory
what is then in quantum mechanics what
is then consciousness well I certainly
cannot define consciousness and what I
find interesting is that no one can
define consciousness at a technical
level where there's even a 10% agreement
within the expert community so I go to
conferences like at University of
Arizona where we have a whole conference
that brings together quantum physicists
neurobiologists philosophers and they
all try to grapple with this question of
how is it that consciousness emerges
from inanimate matter how what is it
it's called the hard problem of
consciousness and technically but how
can you even have that discussion if you
can't even get a solid definition of
what consciousness is in the first place
now perhaps we can agree on some simple
qualities of consciousness without
jumping to the conclusion of what it is
for example consciousness seems to be
capable of making a choice and when it
comes to codes or languages you have to
have a chooser so if you have a C++
programmer in Silicon Valley writing a
compression algorithm well she has to
make choices in the code every time she
has a syntactically free step right
within the rules of her code and an
English language code user has to
constantly choose within the rules how
to choose you know what nouns and verbs
to place in these legal slots and so
choosing if we live in a code Thea
reality then you're going to need some
notion of a chooser because of course if
you were to take a random number
generator and attach it to the
expression of syntactical freedom in
some expression of C++ coding language
or English then what would happen is the
very purpose of the code would would
break down and you'd have gibberish
you'd have gibberish that would be
perfectly grammatically legal no rules
are broken but yet it ceases to even
define itself as a language because the
language is defined a code is defined as
a finite set of symbols or objects rules
on how those objects can be arranged and
then syntactical freedom within the
rules for the purpose of expressing
meaning so it can be like with DNA it
can be expressing physical meaning or it
can or it can be abstract meaning but it
has to express meaning so when you have
randomness and code theory they don't
really go together because as soon as
you allow randomness to operate the
syntactical freedom in a code the whole
thing just doesn't make sense it breaks
down it's choosing so consciousness is
this unique ability to choose between
vanilla and strawberry choosing right
not randomly choosing with beliefs and
rationale and hopes and reasons
purposes I like that yeah consciousness
is choice so then the let's um okay
let's let's ask you about the
localization of it is it then localized
in the human nervous system or in the
nervous system of an animal well quantum
mechanics strongly implies that there
are connections between things that are
just now becoming clear for example one
maldacena and leonard susskind
who are very kind of elite physicists
are saying in the last three years that
space-time is emergent from wormholes
from general relativity and quantum
entanglement from quantum mechanics and
that the wormhole and the entanglement
are actually the same thing with
different labels so that they're
implying a kind of cosmic neural network
formalism of entanglement / wormholes
defining everything the particles of
space and time around us and our theory
emergence theory is also deeply based on
entanglement or connections in this
quasi crystal mathematical formalism
which they're called
empires so in a quasi crystal if you
have a tile here that you exercise your
syntactical freedom to make it like this
like in my example where I said let's
say you had the Penrose tiling and you
had five ways you could arrange it so
any way that you change the arrangement
has these radial beams coming out of it
that drop in density is 1 over R squared
that are called the empire's that's the
tiles that are forced to be on when when
you choose with your choice this one to
be on and so those empires connect and
we are using that notion to model
entanglement so the the gist of your
question is you know is everything
secretly connected at some level that we
don't understand yet it or may not
understand deeply until we have a
successful quantum gravity unification
theory and so I I think yes I think
everything is is deeply entangled and
non-local so that non-local because what
because what happens with this principle
of entanglement in quantum mechanics is
you can have a particle here on earth
that's entangled with another particle
and you can send that other particle to
a different time in other words you can
move it to a different place literally
in time and this was demonstrated
experimentally recently where you can
move it to another place position in
space
and then if you flip this from say spin
up to spin down by manipulating it it
will instantaneously flip the other one
in another time or another space there
will be no signal that transmitted no
notion of the speed of light it is it's
no speed it's just instant it's like if
I take a quarter and I rotate this end
and then focused on the head side
well then instantly it's rotating the
tail side there is no signal the person
in front of you at deli shop or during a
falafel sandwich could then influence
the people behind them or during the
different types of sandwiches could
influence the people in Australia in a
deli in New Delhi who are ordering a
falafel or whatever the analog of a
falafel is there and and and and so that
would be this secret non-local quantum
entanglement connection between
everything and then that is the
potential theory of collective
consciousness sure I mean that's
something that's very interesting yeah
that the whole but this whole planet
acts as a bunch of your neurons my
neurons animals and neurons are all
working together as one earth neuron
going right around the star right I'll
tell you you know even though we don't
understand how to define consciousness
most people would agree I'll say a
materialist very skeptical closed-minded
scientist would say I'm conscious most
most materialists don't deny that
consciousness is real or that they are
conscious and I and if you said well
where did this consciousness emerge and
most would say well it has something to
do with the neural network of the human
brain and so that's an interesting thing
because in in a neural network
architecture we see this enigmatic and
difficult to define quality of
consciousness
floating on an ocean of simpler things
you have these quarks and electrons
photons in your soft matter in your
brain and then there's these emergent
structures the atoms the neurons above
that and floating somewhere in the ocean
of all of that
emergent structure somehow within what
is allowed by the laws of nature and
quantum mechanics emerges this difficult
to explain notion of consciousness and
so the question is well does it have to
be a carbon-based neural network within
a soft ma'am a human brain probably not
can it be artificial can you do it can
you do it with silicon can you do it
with quantum computer and when what if
space-time itself or all of reality
hadn't had mathematically a neural
network architecture then can
consciousness emerge it is consciousness
a general thing that can emerge in the
hyper evolved emergent complexity or
high strata like I talked about a vastly
complex thing like your awareness and
your consciousness floating on a
hierarchical emergent structure where
it's more complex at each level of the
hierarchy and it's so many levels that
you can't even track it down like
science just can't figure out what's in
between but we know that the thing
emerged the consciousness emerged and we
know something about how the fundamental
particles interact and there's this vast
no-man's land of undiscovered science in
between so perhaps if space and time can
be non-local which now experimentally
through these entanglement experiments
we know we know as a consensus now that
this entanglement is real and that it
happens non locally across space and
time and if that is just the tip of the
iceberg and it's a it's a giant Planck
scale entanglement neural network
formalism then sure I would be
open-minded enough to say that perhaps
some strange notion of a
of an uber consciousness a universal
consciousness it doesn't have to get
religious it can just be a
scientifically open-minded possibility
where one says I know of no law of
physics that that sequester's
consciousness as we know it exists only
in the soft matter of a animals brains
it may it may or may not be general but
to be open-minded I think is the key to
key is yes okay then let's ask about the
being alone in the cosmos then because I
think those go hand in hand
yeah how can the being the consciousness
only be localized in just this
carbon-based nervous system of sure of
humans or animals versus the potential
lakes of methane on Titan
yeah or potentially in the cosmic cosmic
spectrum of of the evolution of a
different planet in the habitable zone
of a star there's so many other
alternatives so so yeah walk us down
that path okay so let me start off with
a synopsis what my gut instinct and my
best logical deductive guess is that
reality itself emerges from a mind like
consciousness at a universal scale and
that the mind like consciousness that
the universal scale emerged from the
simpler components so imagine this quasi
crystal code made of pure information
it's abstract it's within the space of
pure information and then you would say
but where does that simplistic code live
and then you say well the simplistic
code which is the simplest thing lives
within the mind of the most emergent
complex thing which just as my mind is
infinitesimally more complex than the
simplistic interactions of photons and
electrons within my body mind system
similarly this abstract hypothetical
idea of this emergent uber con
justice emerged from the simple thing so
you can explain every step of the way
let's say along the way from a
single-celled organism right way to our
brain so that's linear now wrap it in a
circle because quantum mechanics implies
that the future can influence the past
there's a lot of very good work and
papers on that wrap this in a circle and
connect the end to the beginning so that
the origin of the beginning is the end
and the origin of the end is the
beginning and every step in between is
just trivial science where you can
understand well where does DNA come from
well DNA comes from this chemistry and
quantum mechanics we understand that
where does this so you chase it all the
way down and that is called the
Ouroboros model so the Ouroboros is the
symbol that you see in a lot of ancient
symbolism of a snake with the most
complex part of the snake as the head
and the most simple and smallest part of
the snake the tail where it tapers off
to being infinitely small and the
Ouroboros connects the complex part into
a full circle now that's all maybe false
but if true it's at least logically
consistent it leaves no further
questions you don't stop anywhere in the
circle and say where does this come from
you don't you don't have an ontology
like the Big Bang there interesting and
that's what wraps the Big Bang into the
potential right next worm and then in
the next what happens after you go
through a black hole right out the other
end big thing again it's a wrap right
yeah okay so now let's talk about
whether we're first so this so the
future Einstein said that the past
future and present are labels that are
illusionary that the future yesterday
and tomorrow are identically real
physically real and your vantage point
being in say today is the only
artificial label that allows you to
label the difference in other words when
you think about tomorrow
according to general and special
relativity it exists physically
ontologically real and it's even been
connected through these recent
experiments in 2014
that showed that you can entangle
particles across time whether I'm alive
to actually experience tomorrow or not
it's real yes yeah right so in any event
I want to put out three or four
outside-the-box arguments to defend the
conjecture that humans are the first
high technology high consciousness
species capable of leaving their
biosphere you put arguments in place
that we are the first yeah high level
conscious yes I can leave the earth
right out of 13.8 billion years yes one
three three so for your consideration
and I like I like to go against the
grain so many yeah many years ago it
would have been against the grain to say
that humans to say that humans are are
not the first and then as we started
realizing the vast scale of the universe
and as we started realizing how life can
emerge an ultra hot and ultra cold
environments it started becoming
ridiculous to think that humans were the
first and so now okay what I'm saying
yeah it's rebellious and one against the
grain so that's yeah that's where I like
to live yep but I also like logic yes
deductive thinking yeah so here are my
things for your consideration okay first
of all I am NOT suggesting that humans
are the first life in the universe I
think that life probably exists on at
least every other solar system around
every star in the universe
exactly so I let's get that out of the
way okay statistically or
psychologically it's ridiculous to
presume we're the first now there are
ten million species on the planet today
and the planet has the biosphere has
existed for one-third the age of the
cosmos since the Big Bang exactly and in
that four billion years of life on earth
there have been approximately at another
90 million species so the total number
of species is 100 million
over 1/3 the age of the universe yes yes
yes we understand some things about the
fossil record we generally understand
that there's no other animal in the
fossil record that same seems to have
developed abstract thinking to worry
about the past that they didn't pay
enough taxes in 2016 and that therefore
they're not going to send their daughter
to college next year
correct right yes and to have abstract
thinking in the form of mathematics
which seems to be the language that
physics is written in and is Cree and
created iPhones and left the planet and
put the Mars rover on Mars like we don't
see evidence in the fossil record that
any of the other although a vast
majority of our oceans 95% are
unexplored absolutely we don't
technically know absolutely under water
civilization we don't yeah we don't but
for what we see that there's a consensus
solid view in the in the in the
archaeological literature we don't see
that we see we see humans being a
strange case that's that's point number
one point number two is evolution a
pores imbalance so if you have two
animals on the African Serengeti and one
of them is a gazelle and one of them is
a lion and one season a lion brood
mutates such that the Cubs are a full
twenty percent more intelligent than the
average lion within just a couple
seasons they will so severely outsmart
their prey source of survival the
gazelles
that they will drop the gazelle
population below reproductive threshold
they will basically obliterate the
gazelle and therefore obliterate
themselves this is nature operates on
symbiosis that means gentle and subtle
differences between intelligence speed
tooth size etc within the delicate
balance of predator prey systems all
around any ecosystem that's why
99 earth 90 million species have also
become extinct over time is due to some
of these mutations that have caused yes
i'm to be seeing so when they get too
fast too smart too quickly the system
naturally obliterates them that is
evolutionary biology which depends on
synergy and symbiosis knocks them out so
Along Came this one primate that had a
brain a cranial capacity a brain mass to
body mass ratio that was absolutely
grotesquely out of balance there is no
animal on the planet not a dolphin not a
chimp nothing that has remotely close to
this brain mass to body mass ratio and
similarly there isn't another animal
that has the ability to worry about the
past and Link arcs of story between
future and past and this complicated
abstraction that humans have there's
there's a little bit of disability in
dolphins and chimpanzees but humans yes
we are we are we are grotesquely out of
balance with everything else and so we
have dominated the planet yeah we have
the ability if we chose to to to disrupt
evolutionary biology in massive ways
like we already have with the 1 billion
pigs and though yes half billion cows
yes yeah so the point is at this point
number two is that all around the
universe the objective of a biosphere is
not to create an animal that is
grotesquely out of balance in terms of
its abstract thinking and cerebral
capacity than every other atom the shark
is far more evolutionarily advanced than
us but not as abstractly intelligent as
us they have other qualities and so we
got away with murder so somehow the
biosphere wasn't able evolutionary
biology wasn't able to snuff us out as
it should have because we were out of
balance we dominated our spheres of
influence well there were a couple of
those sniffs out with Neanderthals
like that well we almost got snuffed out
in the Cuban Missile Crisis mm-hmm right
and we could get snuffed out if we use
up our resources because that's usually
how how the biosphere snuffs some
species out that gets too smart or too
fast there's other Fermi filters like AI
and yes nuclear war etc yeah so I like
that Leonardo DiCaprio movie catch me if
you can so think of mankind and what
they've got away with is getting away
with murder and the biosphere
evolutionary biology doesn't doesn't
like that it would prefer to have other
things get similarly as intelligent and
have us be just a little bit more
intelligent keep things in balance
symbiosis but we got away with it and
right now if we get off the planet and
can get out into populating other
regions of space-time yeah then the
genie will be let out of the bottle and
this particular biosphere would not be
able to snuff out this high
consciousness abstract thinking third
point okay so yeah this so that so the
essence of the second point is that
typically evolution will figure out ways
and along with these Fermi filters there
will be a a very unlikely hood of the
species getting off of the rock right so
now so I grew up at the time in
elementary school where we were worried
about the the the the bombs going off
the 20,000 intercontinental ballistic
missiles on each side of the Russian and
American side being fired on every Ally
every country who's our friend or
Russia's friend it would have just put
us to a Mad Max world he said it didn't
happen and now with private spaceflight
Elon Musk doing his thing and every
another how close was this rock to
actually not being able to get it was
like a Hollywood screenplay
like as though it was written for
adventure in the nick of time like a
cliffhanger so it seems that we're
getting off the planet seems that we may
be okay but it still is shaky so it's
this how can technology and physics help
us to get along better help to reduce
the scarcity theory right versus the
abundance theory and so moving on with
these points for you to consider so so
the next point to consider is lottery
0.3 is logically
it has to happen first somewhere in in a
universe so yeah the Big Bang now a lot
of the years in the in the 14 billion
years since the Big Bang there couldn't
have been anything in the first place
because a lot of it was just preparing
the stage for a low enough temperature
universe in other words in the early
hydrogen universe well you couldn't you
couldn't you didn't have 81 stable atoms
elements then let's hypothetically say
what has there been nine billion years
to do it or good I like that so let's
take nine million is a good number for
the discussion and then let's say that
it's it's a it's a true statement that
high consciousness capable of leaving
the planet with high technology and
understanding the theory of unification
that had to have happened somewhere
first so then the argument becomes not
whether or not it happened some place in
the universe first but whether it was
here first or somewhere else first first
yeah so what I what I advise people is
to realize that all of the cosmological
models whether it's the big the big
fizzle or the the the Big Crunch or any
of the cosmological models most of these
all of these models really plot the
universe as being able to be much older
than it is now you should measure we
measure a human in terms of years that's
a good a good thing and you should
measure a universe in terms of solar
solar lifetimes so you think you see die
like that
see documentaries and you see these
these big celestial dust clouds and we
call those star birthing nurseries and
you kind of get this false impression
that Suns come and go and there's been
many cycles but this is not the case our
universe is only about 1.4 solar
lifetimes old of our star well no the
average Sun in the universe is about 10
billion years old if it's about the law
if it's larger than our star or around
the size of some some have a shorter
lifetime some have longer but if you
take the average okay it's about let's
say for sake of discussion ten billion
years old I thought it might be closer
to like maybe 6 or less it could be 6 or
less honestly I
but basically almost two of these less
less than two right okay and ten were
the average then it would be one point
for solar lifetime sold so very young
now most of these cosmological models
allow countless thousands of solar
lifetimes old for the age of the model
so in other words we are in an
incredibly young early stage of a
universe so that's point number three
point number four is Carl Sagan so Carl
Sagan years ago in the 70s convinced
Congress to give him a lot of money
through the NASA program the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and he was
convinced based on this reasonable logic
that because there are countless
billions of stars and because there
certainly must be life on other stars
and he missed the fact that evolutionary
biology doesn't like necessarily when
one animal gets so massively intelligent
and for that matter intelligence isn't
exactly the name of the game for biology
it's other forms of intelligent like the
intelligence of a shark or or or a
forest ecosystem sustainable yeah okay
so the ability to thrive and propagate
what isn't necessarily at all related to
abstract thinking ability we're making
an iPhone yeah yeah and what the what
the negative influences that potentially
has on the speed yes actually yeah oh by
the way if you go to a statistician at a
university and you say hey can you help
me to calculate the statistical
probability for something happening like
what happened with humans he'll say no
problem tell me your sample size on how
often it happened and then tell me the
full universe size and you'd say oh well
it happened once and it's about a
hundred million species attempts so that
you so the biosphere played around with
a hundred million different combinations
of the four-letter code of DNA and RNA
and it happened to once he would kick
you out of the office he would laugh and
kick you out of the office he'd say in
statistics we can't take a sample size
of one against
any size whether it's ten or a hundred
million but certainly not a hundred
million and say with a straight face
that this happens approximately one out
of every in other words he said ability
one out of a hundred million it may
never happen this may be the first time
it happened yeah but you can't say
anything but it's odd it only happened
once right so there there we don't have
the equipment though to be able to look
at all the other six is a six billion
year old now star systems then see the
design it's in the habitable zone we do
not yeah but the point is you can't
simply take one out of a hundred million
and then say every hundred million stars
or a couple hundred million stars
there's likely to be this abstract
intelligence because this may be a fluke
what happened here in a very young one
point for solar lifetime University the
first I really like your point is there
five zero point five so the no there's
no point five that when you really yeah
we owe the five was Carl Sagan so Carl
Sagan got this money phase four okay
yeah four or five yeah Carl Carl Sagan
looked and he listened and uh and I'll
tell you he was shocked near the time in
the years before he died he was
dumbfounded that they had been looking
listening to the skies in every
direction they could point these radio
telescopes they were pointing it all the
way to the early universe time wise yeah
they were pointing it in every direction
they could point in and one author said
it was eerie as though you can hear a
pin drop as though we are alone out
there now that's a few decades of
government-funded hardcore experimental
listening that's also assuming that they
have electromagnetism that's pointed in
our direction that we can then hear well
if it's if it's happening somewhere then
it goes out like a like a spherical
blast impact underwater it goes out like
that so that we have to be pointing
there in that mall yes Simon we haven't
pointed it in every direction to rule it
out but yet to the scientists who were
working on this SETI program
most of them admit that they're a bit
dumbfounded as to why they haven't heard
anything it's only none of these
arguments are proof or a slam-dunk but
when you take them all together and you
take then the reasonable you come back
to the reasonable question to say is
there any then is there any big reason
why it can't be us first not the first
life yeah but only the first thing for
this bizarre and unnatural thing for an
animal to get grotesquely out of balance
with the rest of its biosphere so the
likelihood that this is a higher level
consciousness being the first higher
level consciousness is more likely than
a being the first life there's likely
lots of other first life yeah
single-cell plant life animal life going
on but yeah to go pesky out of bounds I
really like your points I really do I
think they're very well articulated and
well summarized that that's good and the
question is can those descendants of
ours which quantum mechanics and general
relativity tell us that the future
exists and can be connected to the past
to the present where we are now the
question is do our descendants speciate
from us of course they do
and our descendants will speciate from
us not with slow evolutionary biology
but with advanced genetics beyond our
wildest imagination they will be born in
other rocks and they will not have our
DNA they will truly be aliens and yet it
will be descendants at the same time can
our descendents somehow have any
connection with us is there some new
physics of the future that allows things
analogous to teleportation and large
systems REME alekhya ler ization can you
move abstract information from one place
to another what is consciousness can it
exist in the in the neural network of
quantum gravity space-time can you
navigate that freeway system with your
soft matter consciousness can you
somehow get in there
we don't know
but but but I would say that if I was
forced to believe from personal
experience that extraterrestrial contact
occurred like I think my bottom line is
I think everybody has to just have their
own opinion because I don't think any
evidence of it is necessarily gonna
convince well maybe if you had
Independence Day landing on the White
House lawn or something but I think that
if I were forced to believe that and say
all right so that that hat that just
happened then the more grounded logical
guess of it is that our descendants who
discover the deepest first principles
unification of everything else and go on
to have such vast science and
consciousness and maybe they can even
group together at will in sort of weird
hive consciousnesses maybe those those
beings may use that ability to make
contacts with their ancestors back here
and maybe they do it in a certain way as
not to disrupt that their own timelines
so maybe there's a reason they they do
it in this kind of mysterious
hit-and-miss kind of way because doing
it beyond the noise right into overt of
a way literally disrupts the feedback
loop between future and present correct
correct so the advanced civilizations
that have we end up birthing out from
this hopefully would be so different
than us even 1% genetically superior
than us they will be living with all
this a new technology and new lifestyles
right they could go back and figure out
how to interact with Ross in a way that
doesn't affect their future or what if
it secured their future what if somehow
the subtle feedback loop between our
future and past somehow is why we're
discovering why are we accelerating
right now like why this exponential
understanding of
physics and quantum computing why is
this picking up speed the way it is and
why now and what if we're in some
entanglement feedback loop with
information or knowledge from the future
now that's weird because you can't
because the only reason the future has
the knowledge is because us back here
the end that ancestors worked on it but
if the only reason we figured it out is
because we've been in a weird feedback
loop with our future yeah so I suspect
something like that maybe it at play but
it's just philosophical fun until
somebody derives a predictable and
rigorous quantum gravity and and
particle physics theory exactly that's
so fascinating I'm so excited and you
you excite me so much about oh ok couple
last questions before we peace out how
about what is the most beautiful thing
in the world for me the most beautiful
thing in the world is the quasi
crystalline spin network and you can get
a feel for what this object is by
looking at our movie called what is
reality on YouTube if you Google what is
reality and then just the word quantum
it'll come up as the first list it will
put the link in the bio so that's that
object is aesthetically artistically
gorgeous it's beautiful at a
philosophical and heart level for me
because it's the very fabric of reality
it's the code there's a code of reality
yeah and that's that's the thing that
wakes you up every single morning and
lights the fire under your that's my
play that's your play exactly the quasi
crystalline spin Network spin net the
qsn the qsn awesome awesome that's the
most beautiful thing in the world that's
a good one problem no one's ever said
that I love it I love it
ok and then how about quick on
maximizing human potential I I really I
really don't like them ISM and every
time I notice that I'm being ignorant or
arguing with a friend or something
ignorant
I calmed down I looked back at my
behavior afterwards I realized that I
was dropping in to the them ISM which is
about egoism yeah so we need to protect
Americans American jobs right because
then it's them and I just think it's a
choice
so if philosophically you want to blame
and follow the the philosophy of them
ISM then do your thing you know but I
think that that when when you find
people who are who are focused on
serving others and making the team
better the team of the planet the team
of their community better somehow it
becomes win-win at the end of the day
every time I see people behaving that
way they have success in their life in
one form or another either financial
success or just some spiritual
psychological success relationship
success and when I look at the them ISM
specialists sometimes they'll amass a
little bit of cash you know but they end
up being unhappy at the end of the day
as though they're chasing after you know
just like chat fluff so I I think that
that that I see a trend of memes in the
world and I look at this Donald Trump
election as the last hoorah
because as as a candle snuffs out or
some funky old antiquated paradigm dies
off it usually has one last day in the
Sun one last just death death thrall
okay and and so I don't have a problem
necessarily with Trump being elected I I
if I could create history I would say
that that it would be you know I would
have I would have chosen for him not to
be but but I also see it playing a
purpose where this last death roll of
them ISM in this cartoon character way
where it's shown for what it is to be
just absurdly rich
dick Ulis just putting it out like the
Emperor's New Clothes but king comes out
buck naked and it's just it made the
facade of him doing the daily routine of
showing off his clothes just a joke and
they and then that joke never happened
again after the one day he went out
naked and so I think that we do see this
surge this week this bulge of religious
fundamentalism which is vem ism and
conservative ultra patriotism and ultra
economic territorialism but I also see
that it's not it's not the hip thing and
usually the hip thing is the thing that
ends up flowing with the greatest
momentum I see it as a death thrall and
and I see technology and the
understanding of nature playing a
pivotal catalytic role if we can have a
breakthrough in understanding reality
which is about physics and at the
deepest understanding of physics may
indeed lead to an unexpected conclusion
in human spirit probably what if what if
the deepest understanding of physics
through through the abstraction of
mathematics as as sterile as that sounds
leads to a logically clear realization
and epiphany that the intuitions of
people who claim to get psychic
premonitions or the indigenous people
who claim to operate on this navigation
of intuition and guidance what a toward
this notion of consciousness is that our
not literally a physical animal with you
what if all of those intuitions turn out
to be legalized validated by some new
physics that allows unthinkable new
technologies but also validates the
spiritual view and in some sense shows
some of the spiritual stories to be just
metaphorical stories right just as it'll
show some of the current scientific
paradigms to be placeholders and and
soon to be antiquated thoughts and there
will be this new
unification of of matter and spirit cool
if you want to call it that I love them
ISM that is a really good way to put it
that's a great way to explain it and the
opposite of them ISM seems to be this
global cohesion yeah so it's a much
longer conversation actually dive into
the present moments need for some them
ISM to prosper and guide the rest of the
world as the United States potentially
because we're not quite in the most
stable sort of position just be able to
say let's all work together right now
but there's some still some crazies
going on yeah planet so there's a much
longer conversation but yeah overall the
idea of them ISM is a really good one
it's a good way to put it into
perspective so and it's a good way to no
longer have polarized conversation right
rather than thinking of them of people
people that don't think the same way you
do as them we think about it as this is
another human being that has had a
different life journey that's had a
different outcome than I have why do
they think the way they do what can I
learn from them well how did I learn
yeah let every situation every human be
a teacher
exactly the hardest challenge how is
Donald Trump a teacher exactly if you're
creative enough you can find wisdom in
that exactly exactly and like you said
it could be the big last big yeah of the
them ISM yeah idea okay and all right
let's do our last question Ike I want to
quick address from you from one before
the last one okay do you think there's a
global ruling elite huh no yes and no so
I think a long time ago there were
global ruling elites you know everything
from the the sort of Knights Templar the
Rosicrucian secret societies all the way
up to trilateral commission the United
States government all right that for a
while was the dominant you know ruling
entity and Club and now less dominant
but the thing is is as as time goes on
thanks to the neural network of the
worldwide web which traffic's
information for
virtually free other than your electric
bill and historically in order to
control you control two things you
control energy and you control
information yes so when I was a kid
growing up in Los Angeles we had two
newspapers three national stations and
it you know and a couple local stations
and if you could control just those few
outlets you could you could as a
corporation you could control the
thoughts as a government you could put
political you know you could control now
forget it you can't you can't control
information and we kind of see that with
media dying right old said right I mean
here you are you're outside you're
creating fresh perspectives that
potentially a hundred hundreds of
millions can potentially see and and and
you're doing it outside of the former
systems of media control so in every way
big and small we are living in a world
that is exponentially becoming
decentralized and the decentralization
is is if you look at it through network
theory or neural network theory
artificial neural network theory as the
system becomes less localized and more
connected than what happens is you you
diffuse pockets of control and we're in
an exponential networking period kind of
what's happening with technologies like
watching yeah and so I would say I said
yes and no so sure there are some last
vestiges of pockets of control but right
now the crowd so as my former life as a
businessman I could manipulate the views
of my customers by the quality and the
amount of money on my advertising right
the messaging and now I can't do that as
easily because you've got crowdsourcing
on Yelp and others and all kinds of
social networks and the bottom line is
people are now going like I go to Rotten
Tomatoes and yeah and Yahoo movie
reviews before I spend twelve bucks to
see a movie
and I'm never wrong if the Yahoo if I
got 5000 regular Joe's on Yahoo that say
they gave it four out of 4.5 out of 5
stars and I got the highbrow critics on
Rotten Tomatoes I never am wrong yeah
but before I used to get fooled by the
trailers if it was a snazzy trailer I'd
get fooled and sometimes it's not as not
not representative of the movie yes so
anyway so I think that decentralization
is on it's is is taking control and
elite control up exponentially out of
the picture and in five years you little
will be sitting back five years from now
looking back today and saying oh my god
in just five years it's so exponentially
diffused and minimized that it's on its
way out
is there also a little bit of benefit of
having a couple thousand benevolent
people guiding the future of
civilization I don't think so I I think
all maybe seven and a half billion or
eight billion should be not
participating in them not necessarily I
see it like a neural network like your
mind your consciousness right now is a
is a sort of emergent thing from one
part of your brain having this sort of
thought form subconsciously and then
another global part of your brain having
another thought form subconsciously and
yet another and another and what comes
out is this dynamic and unpredictable
consciousness at the surface above the
iceberg level of the water at the tip
which you call consciousness and so if
you think about seven billion Minds each
person worried about a different thing
and then there's groups you know like
meetup groups but there's this
proverbial groups and all of the
interaction between these different
groups so you talk about ten thousand
you know people in an elite group well
sure you could have ten thousand people
working on quantum gravity so that's one
elite group and they're kind of leading
the charge on that you could have other
groups working on you know farm-to-table
more sensible sustainable ways to get
our food and and then overall the crowd
still has to vote and and follow the
meat and flow is how it still works even
though there are benevolent people
trying to lead the future right people
still vote with their feet and their
money and yet they go with their energy
okay alright alright I am I'm loving
this conversation I know it could go on
for another hour if we wanted okay very
last question is are we in a computer
simulation I think that reality if you
have to take 21st century kind of memes
and analogies I think that reality is
physically mm-hmm
like a neural network okay it has the
architecture at the Planck scale of what
we would call a topological which means
non-local neural network and and I and
we're we're not that's not a novel
thought there are a lot of elite
physicists saying exactly the same thing
although nobody has the convincing
theory of what the specific architecture
of this neural network is so like a
collective consciousness well just
because it's a neural network doesn't
mean that for sure a collective
consciousness has to exist but it means
that you can suggest that it may exist
without being laughed right okay without
without it being with a straight face so
so I I think I think that
point me to the question again because
now I'm going to the puter Simula so so
computer okay are you a computer yeah
yes you are
what's one plus one you just computed
that yes so you can compute therefore
you are a computer or a computer right
yes but are you a computer in the normal
sense of the word
not necessarily computers generally
cannot invent questions and generally do
not have free will so what you are is
far more than a computer you can compute
but you can also generate novel and
unpredictable questions and synthesis of
things that is more akin to the neural
network story where consciousness
remember we talked about how every
materialist most materialist skeptical
physicists will say I'm conscious and I
think consciousness is real and I don't
know how it works or what it really how
you define it in computers could get to
the point where they could have these
abstract thoughts and be able me well a
lot of people say that that is probably
some people say that's not possible but
that it may be possible with a quantum
computer because what the quantum
computer you have this non
predictability because one of the
underlying premises is that it's non
determinant and playing out that if you
knew all the the starting conditions and
every detail you could predict it so
you're unpredictable nobody can predict
with absolute certainty what you're
gonna do you're you're guided by a
neural network and this consciousness so
I I think that reality is a sort of mind
like neural network but we don't have to
anthropomorphize that and and imagine a
god of the collective consciousness with
a white beard it may be more like this
force in Star Wars or the flow of
intelligent Chi and Buddhism or
something like that but whatever it is
it's more it's more analogous because by
the way the Ouroboros story is logically
self consistent every part has a logical
explanation boom the computer simulation
hypothesis says that we are an advanced
quantum
simulation in in an alien geeks basement
at his mother's house right and then it
leads to the question well by that same
logic if we're statistically a
simulation in the alien geeks basement
isn't he also a simulation in another
universe and it's called the Turtles all
the way down problem which is it doesn't
really give you much satisfying
explanation but the Ouroboros story
where everything is emergent and
explained by everything else including
the Alpha and Omega the beginning and
end is is logically satisfying and and
there are no logical deal killers in it
so I don't think we're in a simulation I
think that we are in a neural network
where where the hardware the software
and the simulation output are all one
and the same thing awesome we could go
on about this and I love your mind I'm
very grateful for you grateful to you
thank you so much for coming on Clee we
have please information inside of the
bio you can check it out there please go
check out the what is reality video it's
so profoundly interesting we want to
thank River studios for the pretty
beautiful space their links also in the
bio want to thank Ron Vargas our
director and producer for doing a great
job we want to thank all of you guys at
home for checking this out again I'm
your host Don socket if you guys had a
good time please give us a like a
comment to subscribe share the video
with other people I've never felt like
more of a three-year-old in my life
learning so much sorry about that and
then again it guys joining us on patreon
you guys get exclusive content get
access to live events ahead of time and
get access to guest information ahead of
time in q and A's so again thanks for so
much for tuning in thank you for joining
us this has been such a pleasure and
tune in next time thank you